people of the internet retro racking
tour here and
welcome back to another episode of harry
potter and the philosopher's stone or
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
depending on your territory i've
realized the past few weeks of doing
these
harry potter videos that people are very
particular
about whether you say philosopher stone
or sorcerer's stone i grew up in the
united states so
i it's just always been sourced for
stone to me i do
know the story of how it actually
oh my goodness hold on hold on that
story will have to wait because we've
got another
battle with peeves coming up i did not
expect that
i did not expect that
all right let's take him out nice and
quick here nice and quick
come on peeps you can't keep up with
this
you just can't keep up with this piece
look at this these flapindos
he can't handle it he cannot handle it
oh goodness now i've gotten all turned
around
it's still playing the music is he still
lurking about somewhere
okay so just to catch you guys up on
what happened last time so
i ended the last episode after a glitch
i had encountered a game breaking glitch
i don't know if it's because the game's
running on
windows 10 all these years later or if
it was a glitch that was actually
within the original game but i found a
little cheat code that led harry jump
super high
and it made me or helped me to progress
past the point where i was so we're
continuing with that lumos challenge we
did not complete the lumos challenge
yet okay so here's where i started out
yeah we were right we were right here
we just came in from there and so then
we walked in this room
here and i went and got the star
which was right in the middle and then
peeves came out
okay so over here on the left there's a
chocolate frog i think that's it i think
that's all that's over here
unless there's like a secret aloha mora
spot or something oh
oh i promise you guys i did not know
i did not know
i just thought i mean this kind of looks
like a good spot for
an aloha mora a hidden hidden location
there
i mean i'm gonna save that just in case
i do need to come back and
if i take some damage coming up soon but
yeah
people are very particular about the
sorcerer's stone versus philosopher
stone
if you're one of the younger audience
and you don't know the story behind it
originally when the first book came out
in britain over in the uk
it was harry potter and the
philosopher's stone
but when they stole sold it to
okay okay that that hasn't worked before
i don't think i've ever seen flupindo
open a door maybe i just need to walk up
to it
but now that makes me want to try it
over here as well
[Music]
no luck oh there is a star behind there
though
we definitely need to figure that out
maybe there's a hidden alohomora spot
somewhere
nearby but yeah it was harry potter and
the philosopher's stone but when they
sold it
to the american publisher scholastic
arthur a
levine actually pitched a different
title
and he he didn't think that americans
would uh
i don't know if it's he didn't think we
would get it or if it's just
he thought it needed something a little
more magical i believe the original
pitch though
was he wanted it to be harry potter and
the school of magic
which jk rowling shot down thank
goodness
they shot that one down because i'm okay
with sorcerer's stone i would have just
preferred it stay philosopher stone
though so it's consistent across all
the territories but but sorcerer stone
is
far far better than harry potter and the
school of magic i mean i get hogwarts is
a big part i get you want to have some
kind of focus on hogwarts but ooh
no school of magic would not have been a
good choice okay which way we're going
to go first let's try this side
because we need to try and loop back
around man they really must think that i
took
a lot of damage somewhere recently
all right go ahead and flopindo again
saving the chocolate frog because i'm at
full health
okay is this where that other star is
no okay i think i'm gonna open these
chests
[Music]
and then we should go back to the other
spot
there's always that point in where any
game has like a branching path you're
like wait okay
which way feels like the logical
continuation
of the level and then which way feels
like kind of the spot where there might
be some secret so i'm gonna go check
this side since we didn't do that yet
and sometimes it all ends up looping
back around anyway so that
very well could be what happens here oh
goodness
look at that flopindo quick on the draw
okay so nothing here except the lumo
statue
all right so what's he gonna unlock here
hope it doesn't block me oh wait
oh okay so this was
make sure there's no alohomora here but
this was the little
kind of a side area this is not the main
progression of the level all right so
let's wait
don't try to rush it we're not gonna
rush it there
all right go ahead and jump off now and
jump there
all right so let's see where this takes
us
oh there's a ghost here
it's nearly headless nick can i talk to
him
oh no i can't talk to him hello again
there we go
have to actually walk into him to get
him to talk hello again harry
are we going to a death day party or
something you found my secret napping
place
secret napping place do
ghosts sleep in the harry potter books i
can't i don't think they do
i don't think they do but hey we'll
we'll allow it
all right so there's another save point
over there
so what is the point of this area is it
literally just to find his
the secret hiding place let's try to
talk to him again
hurry nothing nothing
okay i hear the frog but i'm not worried
about the frog
you mean to tell me this doesn't open
you found my secret napping place okay
nothing up here very
interesting now this right here i mean
let's see does that just fall down oh it
does
it does okay maybe i need to progress on
maybe there's gonna be something else
that happens
let's wait right here i'm gonna go i'm
gonna just i don't think this leads
anywhere
nope just to make sure now we still i
can't forget about
the spot back where we came from
i'm actually going to run back there so
we can take another peek if it'll let me
i have to be able to get through this
door though
and i don't think we can get through the
door
oh it seals it off see i was hoping
i'm pretty sure it was over in that
direction though
is there any way that i can get oh my
goodness
close call very close call can i like
jump through here
oh you can oh come on clearly he can
make that jump
are you serious wow okay how about
alamore on this did i already try that i
probably did
guys if this is your first video of mine
or you're new here
thank you so much for stopping by and
hanging out i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell we post
videos every week here on youtube
two videos per week and i've been
ramping up the let's plays as of late i
have a lot of fun doing it
and you guys seem to enjoy it as well so
let me know if there are any other games
you'd like to see me play i'm definitely
going to do the whole harry potter
series we're going to go through all of
the harry potter games
in the lead up to hogwarts legacy uh but
any other video ideas that you have that
you'd like to see me make
i am always open to ideas so let me know
down in the comments
what you think we should uh do and what
videos we should make or
what games we should play in the future
all right let's see this is so weird man
there's all these
areas but you mean to tell me there's
nothing like
i still can't get over that spot back
there with nearly headless nick like
that's the only point of that area
i mean maybe it's just like a fun little
easter egg that you get to talk to nick
and
he says you found my secret napping
place maybe that's it but
i feel like there should be a wizard
card or something
oh goodness
who is this hey you
i think i'm lost i i think i might be
too dude
let's see are you a slytherin i think
he's a slytherin yeah please stop that
wow and he just got upset very quick
oh my goodness dude that that right
there looks so close to the mark of the
deathly hallows
imagine man imagine if they knew
all right i'm just gonna go and grab
this frog like there's not even that
many things to injure you back here
[Music]
i guess we get hit by the pixie that's
why they're putting them there
all right more beans we are closing in
on 300
birdy bop beans now you mean to tell me
there is nothing behind this
i mean that that looks like a a ripped
painting that i need to
find a secret behind it i am shocked by
that man
same thing for over here there i feel
like there's definitely something we
missed guys
i feel like there's almost certainly
something we missed but
on we go this is clearly alamora door
right here
i guess this might be uh he he hasn't
learned aloha more
no but look here i i open the door for
you my friend come on
let's go come on this way no he's just
gonna
just gonna chill in there all right
that's fine if that's what you want to
do
okay this that's the area where nearly
headless nick is
there we go okay i knew man i was like
this
this just doesn't make sense there's
gotta be more to it
so good thing he didn't follow me in
here because it's just a dead end
all you do is use that switch but if he
follows me here
i will lead you back buddy come on i
will lead you back
he's like nah i'm just gonna wander
around and be lost
all right look around in here
oh i wonder if there's a way that we can
raise this
all right i'm finally starting to get
the hang of these controls guys
the key if you're playing this on pc is
you just have to keep the mouse
very still because it's not like modern
third-person
and first-person games where like this
is me moving the mouse it just start
it really starts to freak out if you try
to turn left right
up and down so just kind of stick to the
w a s and d as you move around and
you'll be fine and then just use the
mouse
even even when you're aiming it's kind
of difficult because
i'll show you right up here like if i
start trying to move the mouse around
it's just see how it's it's not very
smooth like this right here
that's me using w a s and d instead of
the mouse
so they clearly didn't want you to use
the mouse much in this game for whatever
reason i have no idea
apparently there are some mods though
where you can enable uh strafing
to make it make it a little more sense
all right so we have got to be getting
close to the end of this lumos challenge
it's actually spanned across
two different videos at this point but
this one is the longest that we've had
by far
of all the challenges that we've seen
all right so we unlocked another little
platform and we're gonna hit a save
point right here
i still don't think we found that that
area that we uh
saw in the room before that
but there was a star in that area so
maybe eventually it will
loop back around somehow or
possibly that's the last star i grabbed
i i if you guys have watched any of my
other videos you've probably heard me
say
i am terrible with directions i'm
terrible with them in real life and also
it carries over into video games
dude so many chocolate frogs up here
they do not
they do not want you to be hurt while
you're running around up here
plenty of healing opportunities
all right it's oddly quiet in here i
miss the music
okay we're gonna this is gonna be a
scary jump right here guys we're gonna
have to time it just right
do i seriously have to wait for it to go
all the way around again
that is a that is a slow moving platform
right there let me tell you
all right it's getting closer guys
getting closer
all right we gotta time this just right
gonna wait until it's in the middle
there jump all right perfect we didn't
even have to grab on pull ourselves up
okay we've got somebody waiting uh
that's quirrell i believe
so it's very possible this is the end of
the challenge
i got a feeling he's gonna say we did
not get all of the challenge
let's stars out there's a music
collected
oh we did excellence
excellent i told you i'm terrible with
directions
i just uh i i guess we did loop back
around or
perhaps there was never a star in that
place i was thinking about to begin with
one of the two all right professor
quirrell thank you very much
can we do fulfill on this statue again
get a couple more birdy bop beans even
though we are actually
you guys can rewind the video that
screen before totally said we were over
300.
so i don't know how we would have lost
them walking through there but
apparently we did
all right where is the potions lesson i
have okay here we go
friend george are you are you behind the
portrait
it's a hidden portrait
[Music]
really nice work harry got you covered
all the beans we needed for now
all right what
let's find out do
we have this wizard card oh i believe we
do have this one already anything about
us collecting beans
it will be our secret right act like
they're doing something so bad
collecting birdie bot beans it's a
secret no one must know
all right this is a a witch
i'm almost positive we already have that
one but we'll double check
i always like to look through and see
when they were born to
see if they would be potentially being
hogwarts legacy
all right where is the here we go
[Music]
ignatia wildsmith 12 27 to 1320 nope way
too oh yeah we did already have this one
the witch who invented flu power
i'm almost positive i remember seeing
that one before
yeah it kind of stinks that fred george
just give you the some of the same ones
over again
all right so let's see can we go this
way
all right well if it's true to the book
potions should be in the dungeon
which means we need to be going down
state's always awarding points to
slytherin
it's not fair it's not fair
i love how all these chamber the pots as
you go around they just heal
and it looks like we're already late oh
man snape's not gonna be happy
snape's not gonna be happy ron this will
be our first potions lesson i believe
all right does this lead straight to the
dungeons yes it does okay
yikes man yikes
so creepy
all right
oh there he is dude professor sleep
today you will learn how to mix a wig
and weld healing potion
he didn't get mad about us being late
you're late
excuse me i spoke too soon
five points from gryffindor i spoke too
soon
go to the dungeons and fetch the potion
ingredients for the class
uh are we in the dungeons professors
mucus flopperworm and mucus deduct house
points from gryffindor
flower mucus dude come back
like for real for real dude
all right fine flop or worm mucus it is
okay this is the way we need to go oh
this is cool man
this is pretty cool right here i i it's
been so long since i played this one
really the only thing i remember is
flapindo so
oh look at this look at this lighting
right here with snape standing over the
he's like walking in checking on this
what let's make it mad
i sent you to the ingredients
oh goodness
potions with professor snape all right
we'll go get the ingredients
that must be destiny all right
i got a feeling it's something's gonna
prevent us yep yep here we go
oh my goodness dude where am i
come on snape tricked me you could have
totally prevented that from happening
he wants us to be late on purpose again
so he can deduct more points we all know
how snape operates guys
did that not move
oh it just backed it up okay
all right let's see anything over here
no all right
okay where do we need these things that
is the question
not where they are that's for sure
because i don't think i can't jump up
that high no
okay
but i don't think it's gonna do me any
good
if i push them straight ahead as well
[Music]
i think we need we need to activate the
switch to open that gate somehow
yep there we go all right and then
hopefully once we
send this other one down
it will open the gate oh one more
one moreover
i wonder if we're actually going to be
able to use this spell that he teaches
us to heal
there we go all right and it is shorter
so perfect we'll be able to
flip endow this one straight through
and then hop on it to get to the top
it's going to be close enough yeah there
we go
all right here's something what amani
told me
i think that's the molly that's the
molly
all right we got that
oh was i was i supposed to hop on there
apparently i was hopefully it comes back
down
there we go i mean i was waiting for
something to jump out i didn't think it
was going to be
just a standard elevator here all right
anything behind us
no okay you know what i always in spots
like this i always like to double check
for an aloha mora door but nothing there
no secret this time
all right save point right there
i missed the switch are you serious
i was like please don't make me go back
oh i messed up oh we saved that jump
somehow
we saved it all right so
okay clearly we need to get to the top
let's go to the bottom here first
[Music]
see what does that activate ooh a secret
room
oh and it's a wizard card
and we already have that one too
oh wait is that one new
is that one new you guys can tell it's
been a little bit of time since i last
recorded to play this
that one is new okay good good eledora
ketteridge
1656-1729 very close to the hogwarts
legacy time period
but unfortunately not in the late 1800s
which who discovered the use of ghillie
weed
she nearly suffocated after eating it
recovering only when she stuck her head
into a bucket of water gillyweed of
course
the special plant that gives you gills
harry used it in harry potter and the
goblet of fire
tipped off by dobby
okay i mean i want to see this through i
want to see where this ends up
but we've got to remember that there's a
challenge star
back the other way so i don't want to
get too
far ahead and then
forget to go back is that alohomora no
but i bet this will open it up
yep there we go okay perfect this is
gonna tie us back
into that last room oh
very nice very nice okay so we do need
to hop off here just to collect more
beans as if we don't have enough already
all right time that just right and now
we got the challenge star
aloha that door
uh oh
okay wait is this one
[Music]
there we go i was about to say something
has to make that move
or the other platform slide over to us
one of the two
all right another save point okay let's
go
gotta hurry see do they all fall away
yes they do
all right another flapindo just an empty
area of darkness right there we jump too
soon
[Music]
good thing we just hit a checkpoint guys
good thing we just hit a save point
sometimes you just get in too big of a
hurry and that's exactly what happened
to me right there
all right let's go ahead and jump right
there
jump right there oh gotta back up a
little bit harry
[Music]
can i go ahead and alah more of that
from here
yeah that's gonna be really helpful i'll
make it so i don't have to do it so
quickly
and another save point all right perfect
all right i feel like we're making
really good time on this dungeon
see what i did there dungeon okay
all right when i say oh the bloody baron
away from me no need to be afraid of him
harry
no need to be afraid
these dudes out of my way i can't have
them stealing my beans
[Music]
that's ridiculous man i hit him the
first time
i hit him the first time
oh wait might as well might as well top
off our health you know
okay did that open all of them i think
it did yeah
it's gonna be more beans
yeah i knew it's not a spot for a wizard
card right there
you could just tell you could just tell
that was not going to be a wizard card
[Music]
okay what happens now though does it
lock them back
nothing okay no beans that's it all
right
all right wiggin tree bark there we go
oh need to use one guardium leviosa here
whoa too far right there
and then what do we stand on this one
oh see i thought i thought it would open
up
whoa glitch what was that
sounded like five harry's saying one
guardian leviosa all at the same time
okay and that should open this
can we just stand on this one oh wait
maybe now
it doesn't matter if we let that one
shut
there we go just a progression thing
it's gonna open this up
perfect
all right still looking for i think we
need two more ingredients
oh man they are upping the ante with the
platforming here
i don't like this
oh i took a chance and we made it
yes yes please checkpoint
all right is that going to open up a
shortcut or something ah
it did indeed very nice okay are these
moving
no all right good deal not moving
so that means we can just go straight
ahead still cracks me up that this is
how they use lumos
in this game like it like it reveals
uh not reveals but
it's almost like it's a counter to dark
magic or something
of course at this time when they made
this game we just didn't know about
all the spells that we know about now
all right that we cannot get into
from here all right so we're gonna have
to go back down
oh this is kind of scary though do i
just walk off
[Music]
okay there we go wasn't as scary as i
was thinking all right let's get the
timing for this
okay this one's going to close wait does
the first one not close at all
hey i was about to say
all right we still got plenty of time
let's let that one close
and it's going to open back up all right
and the next one should open
and jump harry
perfect okay another save point they are
very generous with the save points as of
late
both the save points and the chocolate
frogs i feel like they are really making
sure that you
you don't miss out on them they're gonna
keep them all pretty close by okay are
these moving
no all right again
just have to time it just right
all right i bet this is the ghillie weed
or no is that the mucus
yeah look at that look at that
flopperworm
mucus you guys yikes
that is not fun to look at
okay so we just need one more ingredient
let's see can i alohomora this right
here
no okay all right so we're gonna go in
here
ah there it is it's like there's gotta
be a switch a lumos
something around here all right another
let's see does that just send it back
down though
yeah it does okay we don't need to go
back down
oh it also makes it move too
another save point yeah see this dungeon
area man
very generous with the save points
got another chest right here what do we
have here
oh the bloody baron dude he actually
hurts you what
oh my goodness i'm at half health and he
just closed that door
did he seriously close that
why is the bloody baron like one of the
strongest enemies in the game
when you see nearly headless nick like
it doesn't do anything to you
[Music]
just gonna make sure there's not a
chocolate frog around here somewhere
oh there he comes dude just get out of
his way just get out of his way
oh aloha mora okay
come on where's your car baby
oh you mean i went through all the
trouble of unlocking that
just for more stinking beans
that means he's nearby
oh my goodness bloody baron is
dominating me right now
no oh oh we're stuck here we gotta wait
for him
all right i don't think i could take
another hit
maybe one more hit but it's it's very
close
i could really use some of those
chocolate frogs that i kept talking
about now
okay we're gonna let him go by all right
and then we're just gonna follow him out
just follow him out don't disturb him
and just go right in here we've already
hit lumos on that
now we just got to be patient wait for
that platform
how do i get up there though
hopefully it's coming up
okay nicely timed jump
yeah i really want to make sure we get
up there even though it's probably just
for more beans
there's always that chance it's a wizard
card no
oh man i feel like that would be the
area to get to it but
okay hold on this is this is curving
back and going up
so we're not out of this yet oh my
goodness
just go for it
[Music]
can i go up higher is there a spot
i don't think so nope
all right still though there's still a
chance there's still a chance it could
loop back around
see here we go it's it's curving that
way but
oh my goodness the bloody baron again
dude no
oh i bet you have to like wait for him
to open the door
let's see what's in here i'm not gonna
go in there yet i'm gonna wait
i'm gonna wait right oh there he goes
there he goes
oh yes yes yes
come on loot back around oh even better
just
a wizard card right here
i got a guy with a he's bald with a
little
red mustache and beard
oh wait here we go folio magic this guy
right
hingist of woodcroft medieval dates
unknown driven away from his home by
muggle persecutors oh
hingis is supposed to have settled in
scotland where he founded the village of
hogsmeade that's cool the three
broomsticks in is alleged
to be hinges former home
interesting i don't remember that guy
all right but does this keep going that
is the question all right let's wait for
the bloody baron let's not let's not
mess around considering we're at such
low health
all right there he goes
let him go on by
oh yes this is it come on chocolate frog
dude
oh not more beans
all right i'm gonna wait it out again
i'm gonna be cautious you guys let's
play it cautious
come on dude come on show yourself show
yourself
where's he at oh there he goes
all right
i have to wait for him again don't i
okay i don't think he'll hit me here
harry's scratching his head and go go go
harry
all right there we go nicely done
okay let's hit this
oh not a switch just a block all right
all right here we go didn't he
and i believe that is the final
ingredient yes here we are
chat heading back into the potions
classroom with professor snape let's see
how
disappointed he is a further three
points from gryffindor should teach you
a lesson
i see you've collected a few challenge
stars
no value here a lesson without you
other students are off to the halloween
feast
join them if you must how you gonna do
that snape come on
we don't even get to learn the wig and
weld potion or whatever
all right guys that is going to be it
for today if you enjoyed this video make
sure you give it a like
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
as well ring the bell
so you won't miss any of our new videos
as always guys thank you so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon